pour ce premier podcast sur les faits
historiques des Yvelines quoi de mieux
que de commencer par l'origine du
département et de son
[Musique]
appellation le département des yvines
tel qu'il est aujourd'hui a vu le jour
en 1964 le 10 juillet une nouvelle loi
promulg de la réorganisation de la
région parisienne cette loi supprime les
départements saine et saoise pour donner
naissance au Département de Paris des
haute scène de la scène Saint-Denis et
des Yvelines mais de nombreux débats ont
eu lieu autour du nom choisi pour le
nouveau dé appartement Charles de Gaulle
alors président de la République
souhaite l'appeler Versailles sa volonté
représenter le département sous un nom
qui rayonne à l'international mais 4 ans
plus tard en 1968 le poète versaillis
Jeant d'Esper propose de donner le nom
d'iveline au département cela fait
référence au pays d'iveline sans s issue
d'une ancienne forêt de la haute Vallet
de Chevreuse dont Rambouillet est le
dernier vestige Eveline vient du latin
syva Aquilina littéralement forêt gorgée
d'eau en effet plusieurs rivières
avaient pour source cette forêt mais
alors d'où vient le S à la fin des
Evelin cette précision s'explique par
l'intermédiaire de Jean d'espert qui
aurait dit avec un S Eveline ça faisait
plus riche